porque con esta segunda invitada del día
vamos a hablar del control parental que
cada vez más aplicaciones están
implementando en sus configuraciones con
el motivo de proteger a sus hijos de los
peligros del internet nap chat fue la
más reciente que se suma a estos
controles parentales que les permiten a
los padres ver en los contactos de sus
hijos adolescentes y también informar a
la compañía de redes sociales sin el
conocimiento de sus hijos cualquier
cuenta que pueda preocupar los el
objetivo es permitir que los padres
controlen las conexiones de sus hijos
sin comprometer la autonomía de los
adolescentes esto se puede lograr
realmente hasta qué punto el control
parental y hasta que otro se puede
considerar una violación a la privacidad
de los adolescentes pues se lo
preguntamos entonces a nuestra segunda
invitada del día y así ahora molina
psicóloga y también escritora de
crecimiento y desarrollo emocional si
ahora gracias por estar con nosotros
esta mañana de viernes en directo
américa de france 24 le pregunto si con
esto de las plataformas estarían
poniendo digamos a toda la carga de la
aplicación en los padres ya que no
estarían haciendo digamos nada para
detectar el material dañinos que pueden
afectar el bienestar mental y físico de
los adolescentes
bueno aquí hay que tener en cuenta cada
aplicación lo que propone es nacha me
parece adecuado ya que el control
parental es jose consensual es decir el
hijo debe dar permiso a los padres para
acceder a esta lista de contactos no
hacia el contenido y la privacidad
también está en el contenido el objetivo
del control parental es consensuar un
comportamiento más parecido a la vida
real los que somos padres conocemos a
los amigos con la mayoría de amigos de
nuestros hijos no y es un poco también
para salvaguardar les pues de los
peligros que tienen en la red aunque la
clave está en la educación claro que
también lo estábamos le estaba diciendo
precisamente en un mundo ideal digamos
que los padres se sentarían con los
hijos pues o conversarían sobre este
tema también los amigos irían a digamos
a la casa los padres conocerían a todos
los amigos de los hijos pero realmente
no está pasando y con un mundo tan
virtualizado con el que vivimos ahora
entonces digamos cómo hacer para que
realmente esta comunicación pueda ser
efectiva y esta comunicación entre
padres e hijos
con este tema tan delicado no cuando uno
es es adolescente pues no cree brechas
ni grietas entre las familias
aquí la clave está en el diálogo
familiar
es verdad que hay depende del entorno no
siempre es fácil y no todos los
ambientes son los adecuados pero hay que
educar en valores
lo que sucede en este tipo de
aplicaciones es que son muy rápidas
apertura es nacha puedes mandar un vídeo
y una foto que inmediatamente se
eliminan pero claro dan mucho juego
sobre todo lo sexual pero es marcha se
puede entrar desde los 13 años entonces
a los 13 años no tenemos madurez
emocional para entender incluso en qué
juego estamos entrando o si hay un
adulto detrás de estos contactos no sí
que el control parental no está hecho
desde me voy a convertir en el espía de
mi hijo sino más bien en cómo ser una
guía un acompañamiento
y hablar con él y con ella de los
peligros realmente que hay en la
sociedad no al final el objetivo es que
vaya a generar un grupo de confianza es
verdad que es muy difícil a las
adolescentes por ejemplo les atrae lo
prohibido el miedo y la pasión van de la
mano y contra más estrictos seamos en
ese control pues van a buscar otras
aplicaciones o las crean ellos mismos lo
cupo como para evitarlo entonces la
clave va a estar sobre todo en la parte
educativa y de valores que es mucho más
lento que el control que pueden hacer
las aplicaciones pero la educación
empieza desde casa desde la tecnología
claro se hará y además después los
adolescentes también digamos que pueden
mentir en cuanto a la edad no en torno a
todas estas aplicaciones y también le
quería preguntar pues a los padres a lo
mejor que nos también en este momento y
digamos que tienen ese temor de ser como
pues sí como un tipo de espía o de
quebrantar esa relación entre su hijo
adolescente de hoy no quiero invertir
privacidad yo no quiero digamos meterme
en tú ya no pero me preocupo por ti por
eso a lo mejor quiero hacer
esta aplicación de control parental o
sea quiero saber qué estás haciendo en
las redes sociales o sea qué consejo
mejor dicho le darías a los padres que
nos están viendo en este momento para
que no se sientan culpables y que el
hijo tampoco se sienta que está
invadiendo su privacidad
claro yo ya el hecho del término control
parental no me gusta creo que no ha sido
un término muy adecuado más bien sería
guía supervisión
educación
si ellos les dices mira sabes los casos
de bullying es algo que conocen
saben los casos de pedraza que es algo
que conocen
y saben cómo se sienten vulnerables
emocionalmente a subidas y bajadas que
tienen si aprendemos a comunicarnos está
ahí cómo te sientes no desde lo que yo
te impongo sino cómo te sientes qué
quieres hacer con esto te sientes cómodo
te sientes incómodo vas tirando un
vínculo de confianza
y no invades del todo su autonomía más
bien ellos lo comparten contigo es
verdad que esto no podemos esperar a la
adolescencia para hacerlo resto de
sabores de hacerlo antes y los
adolescentes no es que sean rebeldes por
naturaleza pero bueno hay unos cambios
hormonales que también le buscan su
autonomía en ese momento y es difícil
encontrar el equilibrio pero ya los
padres sobre todo lo que les haría es
decir que hablen desde el diálogo el
consenso y sobre todo de decirle mira no
es mi intención de invadir te que crees
que papá o la quieren hacer con esto
cómo te sientes con esto como es la
forma más adecuada para ti creo que no
podemos hablar tienes que poder mostrar
la confianza hacer preguntas abiertas
para ver realmente cómo lo sienten
nuestros hijos y no imponer la medida
porque si por eso en estas aplicaciones
también es consensuado el hijo tiene que
dar acceso a ese control parental no lo
puede hacer el padre individualmente
claro ciará y también digamos que le
dices a los padres que a lo mejor
satanistas de alguna manera estas
aplicaciones y el internet como cómo lo
dices bien
el punto de digamos y la conversación
estaría más orientada a la educación
cómo abordamos esto porque si bien es
cierto que si evidentemente hay cosas
que le hacen daño emocionalmente a los
adolescentes y ni siquiera a los
adolescentes a todas las personas que
podemos tener una red social nos puede
generar en casos de ansiedad en fin un
tipo de cualquier tipo de emociones que
podamos sentir por las redes sociales no
pero tiene que ver más más el uso de las
aplicaciones que las aplicaciones en sí
o que el internet en sí no sí totalmente
por ejemplo yo tengo una consulta online
de psicología desde hace 12 años al
principio fue como muy satanizada porque
bien que las emociones no se podían
transmitir a través de las redes y no es
cierto porque te dan la individualidad
el la herramienta no es el problema es
el uso que se da de esa herramienta
entonces por eso la clave no puede estar
en satanizar no hagas esto porque al
adolescente contra más le prohíba más
atractivo le va a parecer y ellos son
que se les llama no ha nacido
tecnológicos o sea nosotros no hemos
nacido con esta tecnología pero yo sí es
un medio de comunicación es como
quitarnos a nosotros el teléfono o los
diarios en su día no somos seres
opciones no nos puedes sin comunicar
pero igual que les enseñas a leer porque
tienes que enseñar a navegar y lo que
está bien para él o para ella los
límites de su cuerpo el cómo se tolera
como una persona le habla las leyes de
aproximación eso es lo que tenemos que
trabajar con ellos pero la herramienta
no puede controlar todo esto es con el
colegio el colegio vas a aprender cosas
pero quiere educar educar en casa
nuestra herramienta pasa exactamente lo
mismo